in this comprehensive tutorial you will
learn how to use nextjs the new app
router and the power of Tailwind CSS to
create a ticketing application from
scratch you'll learn how to set up a
mongodb atlas database and seamlessly
connect it to your nextjs app using the
mongus library in this step-by-step
course Jake lower will help you master
the art of building web applications
with the latest
Technologies what is up free code Camp
thanks for the to the channel in today's
video we're going to cover creating a
ticketing app with nextjs new app router
so this is 13.4 plus as of recording
this video it's like 13.5 right now but
anything should work we're going to
cover all the crud applications and show
you how to hook it up to a mongod DB
Atlas instance for free as well as
Tailwind CSS for our styling if you like
these kind of videos don't be shy about
checking out my channel as well Clarity
coders we have a next off video coming
out very shortly you can maybe find the
link in the description or the comments
below let's not waste any more time and
jump right in so what we're going to do
specifically today is work with nextjs
and we're going to use the new 13.4 app
router that's now stable to set up an
application and you can see how quickly
we can flesh out a front end and back
end all in one application all at one
time we're going to create this basic
ticket app and we're going to do all of
your crud functions so we're going to be
able to create tickets update tickets
delete tickets and read tickets into our
application we're going to do this with
as few libraries as possible and I'm not
going to do a lot of fluff in this
project because I want you to see how we
can quickly spin us spin up this
application then you can grow it over
time let's not waste any more time and
Jump Right In I'm not going to set up a
lot of stuff in this video I'm going to
assume you have no JS install
but if you don't you're going to want to
do that first so you're going to search
for nodejs and you can download whatever
the LTS version is right now so go ahead
and download that and install it that's
going to give you mpm an MPX that you
can install your project with I'm also
going to use Visual Studio code you
don't have to you can use any text
editor or IDE you want but this has a
lot of unique libraries and features
that I'm going to show showcase as well
that make things really quick so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to use
the integrated terminal as well so I'm
going to open up a new terminal window
and I'm going to actually create our
project you can see here that I'm using
get bash you can The Bash shell you can
use whatever you want again you don't
have to follow my but if you want to
follow along and everything looked exact
that's the terminal that I'm using as
well down here so what we're going to do
is we're going to navigate to wherever
you want to create your folder so I'm
just going to do it on my desktop
here create
next app we're going to use
13.43 cuz that's the version we're on
right now so if you want to follow along
exactly don't want any surprises that's
what I do if you're relatively close in
time to when this video is released to
running this project you can also do at
latest and that would probably be fine
as well I'm going to do this just so
it's for sure going to look exactly and
work exactly like we're showing you here
in this video now you can title your app
you can't use capitals and this is going
to actually create a project folder
wherever you are so whatever we call
this it's going to create that folder on
our desktop so we can call it ticket app
or whatever you want let's not use
typescript so make sure the blue is on
no we'll use eslint we'll use Tailwind
CSS we don't want the source directory
we want to use the app router and we do
not need to customize so we're going to
select no here any import
aliases all right awesome so now it's
created our app so now we should have
that folder on our desktop so we can CD
into that or whatever terminal you're
using it might be different so we'll CD
into ticket app cool now our terminal is
there and we can actually open that
folder in Visual Studio code as well so
you can go file and then open folder and
then navigate to that folder once you do
that you should have something like this
so this is going to be the basic of our
project everything now is contained
within this app folder here most of
everything that we'll need so we got our
page our layout and our Global CSS we'll
look at that in a minute we are going to
use Tailwind for this project so you'll
see we have a tailwood configure that
we're going to use and of course your
package.json that you can see all the
libraries that we're using as well I
want to run through really quickly the
extensions I use with my project because
I do use them and it does help a lot so
the extensions that we're going to use
in this
project or that you can use to help is
this es7 plus react redex react native
Snippets and it's by DS
znj d r it has 9.2 million downloads
what this is going to allow us to do is
create boilerplate code really quickly
I'll show you in a minute so if you want
search for this extension in the
marketplace and install it another one
that we're going to use is eslint so if
you search for that it's by Microsoft
this is going to show us airs and
linting in our project you'll see how
that works as well go ahead and install
it it's very helpful shows you problems
before you know there's problems that
kind of thing we're going to use
prettier now this is something that I'm
uh I don't know maybe it's maybe it's
not the thing that I'm brow of but it
formats your code automatically on Save
it's so freaking handy so go ahead and
if you want to install prettier as well
so you can get a little sloppy when
you're writing your code and then as you
as soon as you hit contrl s it's going
to save and format that code and make it
look nice for you so I use that as well
and the last one that I'm going to show
that I use is
Tailwind CSS intellisense so this is
Tailwind labs and it again it gives you
Snippets of code um but if you want to
follow along exactly go ahead and
install that as well with that being
said we should have all of our
extensions installed you can pause and
do that if you would like we can open up
our Global
CSS shrink this down a little we're
going to go ahead and delete everything
out of here but one thing first if
you're using prettier I want you to go
ahead and hit fold control and shift and
then hit P or whatever depending on your
operating systems and then we're going
to search for preferences and the open
settings UI and from here we can search
for
formatter so you want to make sure a
couple things are switched you want to
make sure your default formatter is
prettier and you also want to make sure
it's check check to format on Save
that's going to give you the
functionality that you'll see on mine in
a minute where when I hit contrl s to
save it's going to automatically format
my code so let's go ahead and we can do
a little bit of cleanup here actually if
you want to we can open our terminal and
actually run our project and see what it
looks like so in our terminal we can
open it up make sure you're in the
folder we can do mpm
runev should give you a URL
here we can visit that you can also just
type this into your browser we're going
to Local Host 3000 if you're on the
default port and nothing else is running
on it that's what should show up and
here you can see our application has
been created and it's running we're
going to chop this down and start a
little fresher so let's go ahead and cut
out all of this in the global CSS we can
hit contrl s to
save let's go to our main page here so
this is kind of the first uniqueness of
nextjs so you'll see that we have a
page.js this is almost like an
index.html and like old school HTML
projects where it's the default page
that gets displayed so this is a PL page
that's going to get displayed when we
open up our app let's go ahead and cut
this down a little bit so everything
inside the
[Music]
return I'm going to
delete now we just have this set up
actually we can delete everything if you
want and I'll show you how we use the
other snippet Library so the cool es7
snippet library for react you can do RAF
C and that's going to give you a default
page if you hit control shift L we can
edit all these at once and we can call
this our
dashboard delete out that top react line
we can save this and now we have our
default dashboard set up now to make
routings super quick and easy inside of
nextjs this app router we can navigate
by creating new folders so let's create
a new fault folder and we'll call it
ticket
page and inside of here we can create a
new file and let's call this page.
jsx we can rename this and make it jsx
as
well so here let's do the same thing
let's do r a
c control shift L we can call this our
ticket
page lead out this top and we'll save so
now what nextjs 13.4 is going to do for
us it's going to create routing to this
page automatically based on our folder
structure so you'll see that we called
it ticket page here so if we go to our
application you can see it's
automatically updated we got this plane
Jane dashboard page now we can actually
navigate out of the box without any
other code to that ticket page and now
you'll see we're on our ticket page we
created we can do something else as well
let's create another folder now this is
inside the ticket page folder we're
going to use square brackets and we're
going to call this ID so it's open
square bracket ID close square
bracket let's put this page inside that
folder so let's move that so now it's
inside that ID folder so make sure it's
set up like
that and now we can do something pretty
cool here so we can
destructure
Rams and then we can use that variable
that ID variable that's going to be in
our URL and I'll show you how we're
going to do that so we will inside of
here here we can do dollar
sign like
that now this ticket page doesn't exist
anymore because we move that page so
let's do slash and then we can type in a
fake ticket ID like this and you'll see
that it spits out that variable to us we
actually don't have to use the dollar
sign I don't know why I was confusing
myself so we can do it just like that
and it'll spit out our variable so this
is pretty useful we can grab off that
with our pages and this is going to
allow us to create this app with
basically one page here so that's going
to be our basic setup so you might be
asking yourself what if I need a folder
but I don't want routing to be set up to
it well we're going to use that in this
project as well so if you right click on
app and create a new folder you're going
to do open
parentheses and then create your folder
name so we'll call our components we're
going to actually use this in the
project and hit enter now because it's
inside parentheses it won't set up a
router for this so users I mean they can
type in slash components but it won't
navigate to anyway so we can write click
on this and then for example inside of
here we can set up our navigation
because that's going to go on every page
so we can create
nav.no
rafc
and then we've created our nav
page and it's as simple as that now this
isn't going to be no one's going to
navigate to this or anything like this
this is just a component we're going to
use in our
project that's the basic of the routing
we're also going to have an API folder
that allows us to access our back end
but this will at least get us started
here so let's go ahead and jump into our
layout page now this layout page is
pretty straightforward the only thing
that's kind of unique unque about nextjs
is you're going to be able as you can
see here to use Google fonts directly so
you'll see the default project already
uses a g Google font sets it up here and
then passes it in so that's all set up
nicely for us you can see there's some
metadata that you can set up so we can
call this our ticket app and change it
to generated
by Clarity coders something like that
and we got us all set up here now if we
want to pull something into this page so
if we want to pull a component in it
works exactly like you would think so if
for example we wanted to add our
navigation to every page right now it's
displaying the children so the children
are going to be the pages that we're
passing in so if we wanted for example
our navigation to show up on every page
we could do nav and now using
intellisense you can tab here and it's
going to do the import for you so I'm
going to tab you'll see nav gets
imported above then we can do slash and
then close that now make sure you have
the nav if it didn't do it automatically
you got to type that
in take a look now you can see our
navigation is going to show up on every
page of our project which is what we
would want now you can see our
navigation there as well so with that
being said let's start setting up the
basics of the front end of our project
so we're going to get it kind of looking
like what we want to look like here now
I said we're not going to use a lot of
libraries but I am going to kill that
terminal and we'll do just a couple
Library installs here so we don't have
to use images or anything like that in
this project we're going to use a free
icon Library so let's do mpm install and
let's do at bort
ft awesome slf free- solid dsv g-
icons space and we're going to do one
more we're going to do at Port awesome
SL react D font awesome tell me in the
comments I don't know why it's Fort
awesome at the start of this instead of
font that doesn't make a lot of sense to
me but that's how it is so type it in
exactly as I have here hit
enter and it will install those
libraries we'll wait for that to finish
there we go nice and quick and then we
can finish up our layout page here and
our navigation
page so one thing that's kind of neat
about Tailwind CSS is we can set up our
default colors in this Tailwind
config.js so let's go ahead and knock
that out out of the box here and what
this is going to allow us to do it's
going to use standard eyes color names
that we can create and then if we want
to change things later in our project we
can change it in one spot and it'll push
it throughout the project wherever we
use that previous color so right after
background image we can create a colors
block
here and inside that we can define
define colors however we want so for our
navigation let's just call it nav we're
going to pass in a color now I just
checked out these colors and kind of
made something that I thought looks sort
of acceptable I am not a designer by any
means so pick out any color you want but
this is the color that we're going to
use for our
navigation then let's do
page and we'll enter that as well to
B3
441 this is going to be the background
for our page the background for our
cards will
be
66a we're going to create a card hover
color so this is just when when you
hover over that card itself it's going
to change to a little Lighter Shade
that's going to be 4 F5
E74 we're going to have our default text
color for our entire project is going to
be just an off white so it's going to be
F1 F3
F5 just a couple more here pretty simple
project so we don't have a whole lot
we're going to do a blue accent color
this is going to be the button on our
form when we create a
ticket 0084
D4 and then let's also do a blue accent
hover
color this is going to be 009 F
FF save it so now we got all of our
colors set up for our whole project it's
going to be nice in this Tailwind config
file I think that's everything we're
going to use with this file as well so
let's go ahead and shut that down and
then inside our layout JS we have a
couple unique things that we have to do
with this project for our icons that
we're going to use this is really quick
but essentially when you're loading in
these icons sometimes they show up
really huge so we got to change and then
they um Define back down so it's kind of
weird it makes it look jumpy so we're
going to do a quick fix for that so
we're going to import config and this is
going to be from at for
awesome slash and now we want to use the
port awesome SVG core so if you got it
in intellisense you can put it in there
and that'll get you your config file and
then we also want to import at Port
awesome SL font F awesom SVG
core
styles.css
now after this we need to add one line I
think just one line config do
auto add CSS equals false so now it's
not going to sub in CSS automatically
for us and that's going to help with
that jumping of the icon so we shouldn't
have to deal with that in our
project we're going to change our page
setup just a little bit here so it
defaults a little nicer when it when
everything shows up so we're going to
keep the body tag there but we're going
to add another div now we want
this navigation to span the entire top
it's like a top bar on a website so we
want it to span the entire top of this
project so using Tailwind we can use
class name and set it equal to and then
we can type our Tailwind commands
directly in here so we're going to use
flex for the layout we're going to use
flex column so that's going to show
everything on top of each other so our
navigation is going to be on top and
then our ticket page so on and so forth
if you want a sidebar you wouldn't use
flex column you you'd leave that out
we're going to do H screen which gives
us the full width of the screen and if
you hover over this or the full height
of the viewport so if you hover over
this you can see the exact CSS it's
adding and then we'll also make it a Max
screen so we're going to give a Max
screen size of that full uh viewport as
well that should be it there these are
pretty simplistic again I'm not a
designer by any means and I want to keep
this as simple as possible so let's
surround the children with another
div so you can see here how I kind of
have that set up let's add a another
class name here we're going to use flex
grow this is going to expand the main
page to fill up the whole page we're
going to do overflow y
Auto and now we're going to set up the
color of our page as well now if you
remember we set up a variable called
page but with Tailwind CSS we have to
tell it what we want to use that color
on first we want to use it on the
background
we're going to do BG Dash now you can
see all the default colors that show up
but we're going to use our custom one of
BG page and you can see our intellisense
shows a nice preview of the color and
everything like that so that is going to
be our background for our page and we're
going to use our text so this is the
color text and now we can use anything
we want here but we want to use our
default and you can see intellisense
popping up default text so this is going
to be our default text color now we can
save this contrl s and we should be good
now if we look at our project well we
got to spin it up again so mpm run Dev
in your terminal see that's working
let's refresh this and cool you can see
our Tailwind CSS has worked you can see
our navigation is along the top now we
haven't done anything with that we'll do
that next but you can see it's at least
in the right spot you can see our
dashboard below has the right page color
on it making progress so let's jump into
our navigation and get that structured
out as
well let's go ahead and delete
everything inside this return we're
going to use a
nav tags like this and then we're going
to use a div inside of that and there
are going to be two icons in here and
then we're going to do a second set of
divs below and this can just be our
placeholder for a login system later now
we're not going to do that in this
project but I have an advanced video
that you can check out that will go over
that as
well that I'll be releasing
soon this is not my email so don't email
it I don't know who that
is so this will put a fake email just a
placeholder in our navigation and over
here is where we're going to want to use
our links
and our icons for our project so here we
can use the link that's built into
nextjs so you'll see here it says next
SL link let's go ahead and
tab it'll add it up here make sure yours
is using
nextlink that'll give us links there we
have to add an href to this so we'll add
an hre this is where we're going to link
so this one can just go to our homepage
so we'll just do
slash and then inside of here let's use
one of our font awesome icon so as we
start typing in Tel ense is going to
help me out font awesome icon and you
can see it does the import up here make
sure yours does that as well and then
we're going to add in a specific icon
now you can search font awesome and you
can find all the icons available to you
I've already found them just to be just
to move the project along we're going to
use f a ticket so I'm going to tab here
again and telesense will do the import
For Me Above fa
ticket and we're going to give this a
class name and here we're wanting to
Define how our icons will show up but
we're going to use this over and over
and over again right in our project and
I don't want to type this out every time
so we can create our own class name so
we'll call our class icon and then we
can reuse that in other spots
so we'll Define that in our Global CSS
here in just a moment let's copy that
entire section there and we'll make a
new one here we'll call this our ticket
page Slash new
lowercase and I'll show you how that
works in a minute so here we don't want
the fa ticket icon let's do yeah we do
let's use fa ticket here actually for
this
one let's use f fa
home so now you can see you should have
two Imports you should have an fa home
and an fa ticket from font awesome and
you'll see that it's got everything set
up that's good but we haven't defined
this icon class yet so let's go to
Global CSS and in here we can set up a
lot of our basic rules now I'm not going
to get into all these but Tailwind is
set up with base components and
utilities and things can overwrite other
properties depending on which you're
using so for us we're going to add to
the layer
components and here we're going to
Define two classes to start out with
let's define our icon first and then
we'll do add apply and then we can add
whatever we want to the icon class so we
want it to be a color of text
default and we want the text to be extra
large now we're going to do another one
here that we'll use later to Define our
button so let's dot button and here we
can
do a
hover of no
underline actually want to do at
apply so one thing that's cool about
Tailwind is we can Define things certain
properties like this for certain tasks
so again we we only want it to remove no
underline when people are hovering over
it so it makes sense sense to put that
there we want our B our background so
we're going to do BG Dash
blue dash
accent and we want the hover color so
let's do hover again to be BG Das blue-
accent Das
hover so now we have no underline our
background color our hover set up that
all looks
good we want to do tracking wider and
you can see what that does so if you
hover over it it's about letter spacing
this is the longest line I think just in
terms of what we add to our CSS so we're
going to do w- full we want the text to
be
centered we want the text color to be
the same as our nav bar so we'll do text
dnav we'll do font Das
bold we need a cursor that's a
pointer I'm going to use the
intellisense let's make everything
uppercase we're going to do a padding on
our x axis of four so this going to do
padding left and right and four is not
four pixels if you hover over it it's
actually 16 pixels a py of
we'll do
rounded so this is our border radius is
going to be
rounded we'll
transition our
colors and one more here we'll make sure
it displays
block so that's it I know I'm throwing
just a lot of stuff at you right there
but basically we're just defining what
our button will look like you can use
any CSS for any button that you would
like but we'll get that out of the way
now since we're in this file so we got
our icon set up we got our button set up
make sure you save this and then we can
go back to nav we're not going to use
the button in the navigation but it's
ready for us now so we got our icons
everything looks good there we go back
you'll see yeah that looks you can start
to see it there it's the wrong colors
and the and the setup isn't great but at
least we're showing
up so let's add a tiny bit of structure
here so we'll say class name again we're
going to use flex now this time we don't
want to use flex column right because
we're not we want the icons and the and
the email address horizontally spread on
the page here so we'll do justify
between that's going to space everything
equally between we want our background
to be our navigation color so we'll do
BD BG
dnav and we want our padding to be four
again I played around with these these
you can uh I'm certainly not a designer
you can you can use whatever you want
there class name for our next div is
going to be Flex We want our item
centered these are going to be our icons
and we want a space
X4 now what you'll see here is it's
doing
some mathematics to get our margins so
they can be spaced equally between so it
just makes those icons look a little
nicer and I think that's the basics of
what we need so if we look back
everything looks pretty good right we
got two buttons or two icons here we got
our email this is kind of a placeholder
right now and then we can navigate
around so if we click on the new ticket
you'll see it pulls us to the new page
and you'll see that it's still pulling
that ID down remember this is the ID
variable that we're passing to that page
now if we go home we're back on our
dashboard and that's pretty much the
entire setup of our application it's
pretty simplistic so we're ready to rock
and roll there awesome we should be good
so we want a to add a bunch of
components here so let's create a new
file inside of components and the first
one we're going to create is our delete
block. jsx we can do our normal
rafc that'll give us our boiler
plate cut that
out
and now for our delete block as you can
see we're just going to use like a red X
so we can go ahead and add that into our
project just to get it set up and
working it's not going to do anything at
the moment
so we will just create the icon so let's
do
font awesome icon like we did before
hate how it did the import I don't know
why it did it like that let's do import
font awesome icon there like that better
this will have to have a slash at the
end see I just fall apart when my
intellisense doesn't work let's do icon
equals now I already picked out an icon
so we're going to do fa capital x so
this is literally just the x that you
see the icon that you see and then we
can set up some class names here as well
so let's do text of r r- 400 is going to
be the color of the text itself when we
hover I want the cursor to change to a
pointer so it looks like it can be
clicked on and I want to set the hover
color to be text-
r-200 so this is just going to be a
lighter version of that and that's the
basic of our delete
block let's create a new component
and this is just so you can see how we
can kind of put this all together let's
call this ticket card.
jsx
RFC see here we got our ticket
card here we can start pulling in our
different items so for example we can
pull in our delete block here you'll see
it's importing our delete block slash
like that you'll see now our ticket card
shows up with the delete block now if we
go to our project nothing's going to
show up yet right because we're not
using that ticket card anywhere and
we're not using that delete block
anywhere yet so then back in our
dashboard page
here here's where we can add in our
ticket
card that's again a component that we're
going to import you can see now we got
our ticket card so now if we go into our
project you'll see our ticket card is
just a red X right now but but you'll
see it does at least show up so you can
see how we're kind of using components
to pull everything together here now
these are components because we want to
be able to reuse them right eventually
in our project we're going to have
multiple ticket cards now this obviously
isn't going to look right at the moment
um but you'll see we're able to use
reuse that code
without retyping it or anything like
that all right so the other parts of our
ticket so we have our delete block we
need our priority
display so let's create a new file we'll
call it PRI
ority spelling is tough for me sometimes
RAF CE get our boiler plate there now
for this it's kind of cool we have the
the five like fire icons and depending
on how hot this project is no pun
intended is how many are filled up with
the with the project so we're not going
to set any of that up quite yet but we
do want to add in our icons so let's add
in five of those icons let's say font
awesome icon imported better this time
so I like that and for this we're going
to do a icon that
[Music]
equals fa
fire you'll see we did the Auto Import
there as well let's get five of these so
there's one 2 3 4 five now prettier
watch this magic contrl s
boom we're getting
somewhere for our class name oh I should
have done this first huh we can do text-
R d400 just for now so these are all
going to be hot at the
moment we can copy that
I should have done this first paste it
below Okay cool so we got our five icons
here now just a little bit of styling we
want these to show up horizontally so
we'll do
Flex we'll put them all at the start so
we'll do justify start and we want to
align them to the Baseline of whatever
the container is and then they'll all
show up that looks good these are going
to go in our ticket card as well now
these are not set up correctly
but we can at least throw it in here so
we'll do our priority
display take a look at that look at that
stuff is showing up in our ticket cards
automatically okay so let's go ahead and
rifle through the rest of these we got
our priority
display we wanted a progress bar as
well
RFC delete this one out this progress
bar is pretty cool we use two divs
essentially to set up an outside div
that's like the unfilled part of the bar
and then the inside div which based on a
percentage is going to fill up the
progress uh bar that we see so we'll use
a class name for this top div we'll say
we want it to be width
full
BG Gray 200 that's going to be the
background
color rounded full so this is the Border
radius so it's going to give it that
rounded look we don't want round we want
rounded this is just the height so we're
going to give it a height of
2.5 and then our internal bar so this is
going to be the internal bar that fills
up we can use BG blue 600 as our color
again you can play around with these the
same height of
2.5 and we want it to be
rounded
D4 now we're also going to use the
style variable here so we'll use
style and this is going to be to get our
percentage to show up correctly so we're
going to do style
equals in double curly brackets we're
going to do a
width of 75% right now so we're just
hard coding in these values we're going
to pass Dynamic values in a minute but
this is you can kind of do it however
you like or however you like to set up
projects but I like to kind of get a
look or feel without using the database
data to make sure everything works and
then add the rest of that in as we
progress but this should be good
here back in our ticket
card we can do
progress
display cool this one one probably won't
show up right because yeah it's just
going to fill up everything at the
moment we'll get that adjusted in a
second it would help if I spelled width
right as
well width of
75 now you'll see it it shows up okay
it's not formatted correctly but you get
the idea our next component we need a
status so we want to do started done or
not started you can do whatever statuses
you want as as well but inside here
we're going to do a status display do
jsx you know how to do this RAF
CE let's use a span for this so we're
going to use span
tags and inside here we're going to do
some formatting to get kind of that
rounded look so we're going to
use
inline block
rounded P you guys are probably going to
be like you round too many of your
Corners I I'm not a good designer like I
said so if anyone wants to help me out
join the join the Discord let me know
you'll help me style my next project so
we'll do to text extra small font semi
bold text- gray
d700 and then we're going to hard code a
in here so depending on the status it's
going to be color different but for
right now we can do the done color which
is going to be BG D green
D200 and then of course we're actually
going to have the status in here so
something like that for now is fine um
because we're using the green color but
eventually this will be
dynamic then in our ticket
card we can add in this status display
as
well
awesome yeah I think that looks pretty
good let's go ahead and maybe format up
our ticket card a little bit so it looks
a little more like our end
project so we are going to have an
outside div around everything so let's
leave that and let's set up our class
for this so it's going to be Flex we're
going to build it vertically so I'm
going to use flex
column
the background color we're going to use
so BG card we're going to do a hover on
this because you can click on them
of BG card- hover remember we set that
up
before we're going to do rounded a
medium because you guys know I love
rounding those Corners shadow of large
just to give it a little drop shadow
padding of three and a margin of two
now on top we have our priority display
and our delete block I just have these
in the wrong order so let's put our
priority display on
top now these are going to have a
div that wraps around them so let's put
a div around the priority display and
the delete block here let's add some
classes to it so there going to be
spread out along the top as you can see
here we'll set up our class name we'll
set it equal to flex margin bottom of
three just to give it some spacing below
this going to wrap around
everything now we're going to use one
more div around the delete block this is
going to slide it clear to the right so
let's wrap another div around the delete
block we can do a class name of ml l-
Auto so this is going to automatically
give us the correct amount of margin on
the left to slide it over so we can
slide it clear over to the right we save
this you can see our Bottom's still
messed up but our top is looking
better now the next thing I want to do
is I want to set the H4 tag and this is
going to be the
ticket
title and below that we can do a
horizontal row let's do a class name of
hpx let's do a border of zero let's make
the background our
page and a margin bottom of two do slash
and then close that so these are the
self- closing
tags let's do a p here for our
description of our ticket let's do a
class name of wh
space Dash free-
wrap so what this is going to do is it's
going to save the returns that we make
in our ticket so if we do like a
paragraph and then a couple returns and
then type some more in our ticket
description that's going to show
up
okay so that's good enough for our
ticket right now if we look we'll see
yep we're getting closer now you might
wonder why does your H4 look exactly
like the P tag well remember we deleted
out all of our Styles so those aren't
styled at the moment so if we want to
fix that we could go back into Global
CSS and we could set up some of those
default Styles so the one thing we want
to do here is we can and create an at
layer
base for our H1 comma we'll do H2 H3 and
H4 um these are the ones that we're
going to use in this project we can do
at
apply font Das bold so this is going to
give every one of these bold
font and then for the individual sizes
we can do H1
we can do at
apply
x-4x LL for
example let's copy that we'll do H2 H3
and H4 we're can do an H2 H3 H4 for this
one we can do 3 XL 2 XL and
XL right now for our P tag
let's do at
apply text-
smm and let's do
text- default text make sure it's
colored correctly as well so now we
should have everything done there if we
go back you can see our ticket title is
better and our P tag is formatted as
well so that all looks
fine now we can go back to our ticket
card out of some of these I've gotten a
little
messy go back to our ticket card let's
continue formatting
this so below our
paragraph This one you're going to have
to trust me for the moment we're going
to do a flex Das grow empty div so what
this is going to do is it's going to
make sure that all the ticket cards are
the same size regardless of how much
font they have inside of them just a
preference thing if you don't like this
you can remove it but I like I think it
looks good with them all being the same
size we'll do another div here now this
is going to wrap around our
progress and our status display so start
the div there end it
here let's do class name for this one we
want to do Flex let's do a margin top of
two that will look good and then the
progress display we're going to put a
div around
that because we're also going to add the
date time that the ticket was created so
let's say class name
here let's do flex and flex
column then inside here again all
placeholder at the moment but we're
going to do a P tag of our date
time
0831 SL 23 at
10:43
p.m. that looks good let's get that
formatted to while we're at it this
one's going to be on the left side so
let's do this of a
text XS so a text of extra small and a
margin y of
one that should be
good and then for our status display
this is the one we want to scoot over
so for our status display let's give
this a class name of margin left Das
Auto Flex items
dend div div okay so now we should have
a basic structure
here cool so you see we got our ticket
our progress bar our status our time
everything is kind of looking good the
hover works all that is fine you'll
notice though that the tickets are
taking up the whole page we want to get
that fixed but it looks okay for the
moment let's jump back to our code our
ticket card is looking good let's go
back to our page now remember this is
going to be our main dashboard page of
this project so this is where all of our
tickets are going to display let's do
some basic Styles in here inside of this
div let's do a class name of
p-5 and this probably has the coolest
part for me of Tailwind uh that you'll
see here in a moment and then we're
going to use another div around the
ticket so we'll do div class
name now we can do some styling here
based on screen size so that's what I
was talking about that's really cool so
on our smallest screen we're going to
have the tickets take up 100% of the
space like they are now if you're on a
phone or something like that however on
this huge monitor that I have I don't
want it to show up like that so I'm
going to say if the screen is large so
at least a large screen and you can see
how this is defined and you can actually
change the definition as well but we're
going to use the default ones so if we
have a large screen we're going to set
it up with a grid and we're going to do
grid calls 2 so there's going to be two
columns however if it's an extra large
screen we want to do grid
C-4 so if it's kind of a if it's a large
screen we're going to use two columns if
it's a big screen we're going to use
four
columns and again this is I mean you can
change that to be whatever you would
like as well so we're going to wrap this
div around all of our
cards let's actually create four cards
since that's the largest that our screen
will
be and you can see now it looks kind of
nice right so now we have our four
tickets spread out because we're on an
extra large screen now if I minimize
this window or Shrink it up you can see
right there that it auto adjusts this is
what like a phone would look like and if
I slowly drag over you can see this is
where it decides it's a large enough
screen to have two tickets and this is
where it's large enough to have four
tickets now why did I have it jump from
two to four just preference again you
can make it three or whatever you wanted
to do do but that's how that's what I
thought looked the
best so that's going to be our basic
setup there so now we have kind of the
the basic structure of our app we have
the routing setup we have the ticket set
up we have our main
display the thing we want to do next is
to start looking at setting up our
database so we're going to use mongodb
ATL lless this is a free free to set up
so you shouldn't have any issues there
and I'm going to kind of walk you
through that process as well if it's new
to
you I'm also going to use so what
lets us do is in mongod DB we
don't Define types like you do in a
traditional relational database so you
don't say that the title has to be a
string and that the priority is one
through five like a number you can't
Define things like that but Mongoose
allows us to have that data Integrity so
I really like that as well and it also
actually kind of makes setting up and
connecting to the database a little bit
easier so let's go ahead and kill our
server this is just so we don't forget
here or so I don't forget let's go ahead
and add in those two
packages and this might be it for us too
in terms of packages so let's
mpm let's do mongod DB and then let's
also do space
ah you need to do mpm in
install space and then those two
libraries so this is going to give us
the packages that we need here that
should be all set up now we can actually
create our mongod DB so you can search
for mongod DB Atlas
maybe mongod DB Atlas we'll click on
that first link go ahead and sign in now
I'm going to skip through this part but
you can sign in you can use your um
Gmail or you can create a new account
whatever ever you want to do you can do
it for free so go ahead and sign in and
sign
up now once you've signed in you'll
accept the privacy policy or whatever
you need to do
there it might ask you some
questions I'll buzz through that when it
gets to this screen we can go ahead and
fill this out because we are going to
use it so if you already have one set up
you can uh we can even hit I'll deploy
my database later so you you should look
at this screen no matter what you might
have came to that preview one or if you
already have signed up before you might
come to something that looks like this
but at any rate we need to create a
database
cluster so what we're going to use is
the m0 which is the free version you see
it's running on AWS it has a name
everything like that we can leave all
that defaulted let's go ahead and hit
create we're going to need a username
and password eventually so you're going
to want to set that up I'm going to go
ahead and change mine to
admin you can leave that password as it
is as well um but we do want to save it
so let's go back in our code and just as
a placeholder for right here inside the
ticket app itself not inside the app
folder let's create actually click
anywhere in this blank space a new file
and let's call it env.
local this is a special file that nextjs
is going to pull in for our environment
variable
now paste your password in
there and maybe paste your username as
well above it as a placeholder for right
now so we'll go ahead and create that
user where would you like to connect
from so you can add your current IP
address
here it's already been added um we might
actually do a change this as well just
to eliminate any problems but we can go
ahead and finish and close for now and
go to overview
that looks pretty good if you want to
open this wide open for right now just
so you don't have any problems you can
go to network access down here now I
don't recommend you do this for every
project but we can add another IP
address and we can allow access from
anywhere confirm so now we're going to
have no problem connecting to it now
click on database and we're going to go
back here it's probably still deploying
our database at the moment
once it's done uh we don't want to add a
tag I'm just going to hit okay there um
once it's done you'll see cluster zero
it has a little green thing next to it
you can think of a cluster as a
collection of
databases we're not going to have
multiple databases we're just going to
have this one then we can go to browse
collections now here we can go to add my
own data we can enter a database name
and then we can also add a collection
name wow so in ours for example we could
call it
ticket
DB and our collection let's call it
tickets plural hit create so that should
be good now we could add fake data here
we could go back and create it and kind
of import it what I'm going to do is
we're going to leave this set up as is
we're going to go back and connect to
our database and then create the model
of our data so what our data is going to
look like and then we'll just start
adding data into this database and see
if we can get that working so let's go
back to overview here go to connect
we're going to hit this top one nodejs
go
drivers and then here you'll see our
connect string here that we can steal so
let's copy that go back to our code and
in our code let's actually create our
connection variable so let's go mongod
dbor urri equals
and then we can paste in this little
snippet here now if you have a different
username you need to change this
username mine was admin so I'm not going
to change
mine and then your password obviously
you're going to use your password I'm
not going to leave mine running so I'm
going to delete that out and then you
can delete this stuff
below let's also cut off this end here
so I'm just going to do to the Slash and
I'm going to do ticket DB or whatever
you called yours database so again you
got to use your information
here um but if we go back to
collections you can see what you called
your database as well so I called mine
ticket DB awesome now for ours it's
relatively simple we only have one model
we're just going to use a ticket for
right now so let's do a new folder let's
put this in parenthesis because we don't
want to route to it or anything like
that and let's call it models and inside
here we can create a new
file we can call it ticket.
JS capital T ticket. JS in this file we
need to import a couple libraries so
let's import
mongus from
mongus do comma and then Capital this is
important capital s c h m for
schema this is going to give us mongus
and the schema that we need we're going
to do mongus doc connect
to connect to our database we're going
to use our variable that we just set up
so process.
env.
DB
DB uncore
URI brain locked up couldn't remember
what I called the variable so make sure
this is the variable that we set up in
the mv. local we're going to get a
promise we're going to use our global.
promise
here and now we can Define what a ticket
is so here we can create our ticket
schema and this is going to be what sets
up
our data Integrity as well we can count
on a ticket being created a certain way
so it's going to have a title which is a
string going to have a
description which is a
string going to have a category which is
a
string it's going to have a
priority which is going to be a
number going to have progress which is a
number Status which is a
string we might even want like an active
flag something like
that that's a booing so like a true or
false that's later if we wanted to have
like an archive functionality or
whatever it might be now we're going to
do comma and we're also going to
add
timestamps true so the time stamps true
that's going to give us a created at and
an updated at date so it's just going to
be helpful to our project to have that
in it as well so now that we have that
we can create a con ticket and and set
it equal to
mongus do models make sure that's
plural. ticket
or so that's going to be if it exists
already so if it exists already we're
going to grab grab it
or we're going to create it if it
doesn't exist we'll do ticket ticket
schema like
that
export default ticket that's it pretty
easy and that's all we need to do to get
our database hooked up connected and all
that
jazz now we can go ahead and start
creating our
API so as you might guess we're going to
use the app folder again we're going to
create a new folder and we're going to
call it API so this is going to be how
our application is going to act access
our database we're going to create a new
file inside of this and this is called
route.jpg
post delete whatever we might
need we are going to use our model so
let's do import ticket now look it's
models it's going to import it from our
folder All That Jazz that looks
good and then this one's important
because it's a little weird let's use
next
response and make sure this comes from
next server and now we can create our
first function so the first thing we
want to do with our database in
particular we don't have any tickets in
it um typically you might fill it with
dummy data or whatever you want to do
I'm just going to create something to
help us add tickets and then we can test
it that way so let's do export
async function
post and let's pass in requests so we're
going to do it just like that and in
here we can Define our post request so
posts are going to be how we create
tickets we can do all these inside of a
try catch just to make sure we don't
have an error if we do have an error
let's go ahead and Define that first we
can return that response so let's return
next response
Json inside of here we'll say we want to
pass a message
back and that is error and then we also
want to pass back our error as well we
can do a comma after this curly bracket
and pass a status code as well if we
would like of 500 because it failed okay
so that's going to be our error and this
is actually you'll see how super easy
this is so to create a ticket we're
going to to get a request and that
request is going to have ticket data on
it so we're going to create a form that
allows people to add data and they're
going to attach it to the request and
then we're going to pass it to the
ticket and we'll create that next so
you'll be able to see it so we're going
to create a const for our body and we're
going to set it equal to and we're going
to await whatever was on requ request.
Json so we're going to grab off the body
data and using
that ticket
data this is the variable that we're
going to call it we'll call it form data
we haven't created it yet we will we'll
call it form data we'll assign it to
ticket data and then we're just going to
create the ticket so we're going to wait
ticket. create this is a mongoose
function we're going to pass in our
ticket data and that's it then it'll
then it will create the ticket for us
now we also probably want to create a
response as well so we'll do return next
response the message that we want is no
longer an error so we want this to be
ticket created we can delete out this
error and we can pass a status back of
2011 which I think is object created or
successfully created or whatever so this
this is all of our post function now
again we don't have any way in our UI in
the like user interface now to get that
data and create the ticket but this is
the backend setup for it so with that
being said let's go ahead and create our
form that's going to allow us to create
tickets so let's open up components
let's create a new file and inside of
here we can do edit ticket form
jsx actually we can simplify that let's
just call it ticket form. jsx RF
CE we're going to do a couple Imports in
here and I want to make sure we get them
right so let's go ahead and do those
let's do import use
router now this is the weird one so if
you do the default one it's next router
and that's not what we want so we want
next slash
navigation and then below that we want
to use import
react use
state from
react now one other thing that we want
to do here so we're going to in these
next projects they're using serers side
JavaScript by default but sometimes we
want to use the client side JavaScript
so in this case we want to use client
side JavaScript because we're going to
use forms and have actions based on it
and different things like this so at the
top we have to explicitly state that we
want to use the client JavaScript so
we're going to do that so we're going to
use client now for our ticket
form this is pretty simple we're going
to set up our ticket and we need some
default data out of the
box so our starting data for our ticket
is going to be starting
ticket data like this we can set it
equal to let's give it a title of blank
a
description of
blank a
priority of
blank oh don't forget your call in there
a priority not a blank a priority of one
a progress of zero
a status
of not
started and a
category Hardware problem these are my
categories so you can do whatever you
would like so this is going to be our
starting ticket
data and then we're going to use that to
set our state so this is going to be a
state managed form so every time they
change something we're going to update
the state and keep track of that so we
can pass that data eventually onto our
API to create the ticket so let's use
const form data remember that's a
variable we used in the API eventually
and we'll call set form
data we'll set that equal to use State
and then we're going to pass in the
default state so the starting State here
and the starting State we divined above
in the starting ticket data so this is
going to give us the setup for our state
out of the
box now we want to return our form so
we're going to have a form here
something like that we're going to have
a div let's do some basic styling here
let's do a class name of
flex justify
Center I'll just Center our form
and then inside of our form we can start
getting things set
up let's have an
H3 and this will just say create your
ticket this is also going to be our
update ticket ticket page eventually so
that's going to be dynamic here in a
moment but for right now we'll leave it
like that as our
H3 we'll do our first label of
title and then let's do our first input
box as well and then we'll do some quick
styling here so let's do input let's do
ID equals
title name equals
title type equals
text on change
equals we don't have this yet curly
brackets let's do
handle
change
let's make this required so required
equals
true and the value
equals form
data.
title then we'll do slash self- closing
here now you see that auto formatted
everything for me nice and pretty now we
don't have a handle change that's an
issue let's go ahead and set that up
real
quick let's define it up here we'll do
const handle
change it's going to get an
event we'll pass that
in we're going to get the value that we
want to change from e. Target do value
like that and then we're going to get
the name of what we want to update from
e
target.
name now we need to set our form data
remember we're going to use this state
function that we defined do set form
data we're going to pass in our
previous
state so we're going to first use
everything from our previous state now
make sure you spell this the same I
spelled it
differently we're going use everything
from the previous state and then we're
just going to overwrite the one thing
that we wanted to change so we're going
to do
name and set that equal to value and I'm
getting
these from above here I need another
parentheses here so it gets
[Music]
returned and that means another
parentheses here there we go so this is
going to update our state with our
handle change let's go ahead and spin
this application up
again we got some issues here but we'll
talk about it real quick should be easy
to
fix go back to our application we can
refresh it now remember if we click on
the new ticket we're not loading in the
form yet so nothing nothing happens when
we navigate to here we need to do that
first so on that ticket page inside the
ticket page folder inside the square
bracket ID we have the ticket page right
now we're returning this
instead let's Import in our
ticket
form like
that and now when we go to that page you
can see we have our nice ticket form
here now it's not styled very well but
we can take care of that really quick
too so I got some very very quick basic
styling
here we're going to style our form we're
going to do at apply now why am I doing
it in global CSS
well if this is a real project if this
is something that you're going to grow
and we might even continue to grow on
this channel you want to be able to
reuse this right so I want to set up the
styling for our forms so for the most
part if we want to do another form it's
ready to use out of the box so so labels
will do margin top of
four and then for our input comma select
comma text
area we will do at
apply margin of one rounded because you
know I love those rounded corners and a
BG of
card padding of
one that should be it I don't want to
get too crazy with the styling you're
probably going to make it your own
anyway so you see we got a little nicer
format there I like
that let's go back to our form so now
we're back on our ticket form page I
apologize for all the tabs
open this is actually how I code too
with all these tabs
open
so go back to our ticket form let's get
the rest of this fleshed out and then we
can start adding tickets to our database
so on our form let's go ahead and add a
few styles to this as well now why
aren't these in the in the global CSS
they they could be you know they're
they're kind of specific so you might
not use these on every form you use so
that's kind of where I draw that line
but it's totally up to you these could
go in the in the overall form as well so
we'll add a method as well so we want to
post our
data and then on
submit we want to create another
function called handle
submit and we'll use that now if we save
this it's going to freak out because we
don't have that yet so up here we can do
const handle submit
submit
equals something like
that this might be the farthest I've
ever gotten coding without using a
console.log but we'll just have
submitted for right now as we create our
form out here so we should be good
everything should be created now let's
copy all of this so we're going to copy
the label and the input paste it below
let's call call this
description
description paste paste that all looks
good the type is going to be different
well actually the the input is not an
input it's a text area that we're doing
this time so we don't need the type we
got the ID the name the
onchange we're still saying it's
required the value is correct we can
make the rows however many we want we
can set rows equal to five that should
be
fine now let's take a quick peek at this
just because now we have our form um the
class flex and all that jazz so now you
can see it starting to look a little
nicer so that's our description let's do
our categories now you can dynamically
populate these eventually you can hard
code them for right now we're going to
hard code our
categories we'll do another label inside
of here we can call this
category we're going to use a
select and inside that select we're
going to give it a
name which is
category a
value which is form
data.
category
an on
change of handle change so we we coded
that up dynamically so we can use the
same for everyone here that's going to
be our select now we just need our
options so for our option we're going to
have a
value which is equal to now for example
what do we say our default was Hardware
problem
we can have a value of Hardware problem
and we can show Hardware problem
here let's copy this let's just give
another maybe three
categories do software
problem and let's do
project make sure the values changed as
well
sometimes these are different so you
might want something displayed
differently to your user um than the
actual value so that's why you have two
options
there look at this you'll see our drop
down is nice that
works after this let's do our label for
our
priority we're going to do a div around
all these so they show up in a
horizontal
line we'll do
input we'll do an ID that
equals
Priority
One a name which
equals
priority a
type which is
Radio on change which is handle
change a
value which in this case equals
one just save so that would format and
then below the value let's do checked
equals let's look at our form data so
this is going to decide whether which
one should be checked at the
moment
so if our priority equals one so I'm
using two equal signs here I'm using two
equal signs for a specific reason I want
it to not care about the type so I want
it to check it if it if one equals the
number one and I also want it to check
if one equals a string one so that's why
I'm using two equal signs as opposed to
three
there so that all looks good and then we
just need a label
below that and I'll show you why here in
a minute of
one that all looks good let's copy
that paste it below now starting with
this we're going to go
two two for the value two for the
comparison and two for the
label this will be our three four
five let's slide up here's the last two
so here we're going to do our one is
going to be changed to a three three
three three
four four
four
five five five five cool so now we
should have all of our priorities
done let's go ahead before we look at it
let's just do another one here let's do
label for our
progress now I did this progress bar
because I wanted another type in here I
don't know if you'd use this in a ticket
situation I guess it could be kind of
useful but um it allows us to show
another thing here so type equals range
ID equals
progress name equals
progress value
equals form
data.
progress let's do our Min
equals zero do our Max equals 100 so
it's going to be a progress bar from one
to
100 I save this just so it would format
below Max we're going to do on change
equals you guessed it handle
change
that should be
good this might be our last one nope we
don't want a stat not status tags let's
do
label of
status and this kind of like our other
one we're going to use a select
box inside the select box we have a name
of
status we have a value equal to form
data.
status have an on
change handle
change and then we have some
options
so first option has a
value we'll do not started now this is
we can do this as kind of an example of
how this could be different although not
much different so here we could do not
started with capitals and here lowercase
or whatever you might want to
do do a second option third option this
one we'll do
started
started this one let's do
done done
that's our select box and then finally
we are here let's do our
input type equals
submit class name now luckily we already
typed all that right
BTN and the value equals this will be
dynamic in a little bit so it can be
update ticket but for right now create
ticket okay let's take a look at what we
got
cool so depending on um if you want this
button wide or not that could be
different but other than that it looks
pretty good make sure everything works
looks like we can select stuff change
stuff
type that looks
great if you wanted to change this
button to look more like uh like a
smaller button you could do like a Max
width of extra smaller
something if you go here now it's more
like a button doesn't particularly
matter to us um but if you want to
change it so what we're going to do next
is we're going to actually hook this up
and then we will create our our first
ticket in the
database so let's see if we can get a
ticket actually submitted so let's
scroll
up
and we're going to edit our handle
submit here let's go ahead and delete
that out the
console.log we're going to get an event
so we'll pass in
E we're going to prevent default so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
prevent the form from doing its normal
default Behavior so we don't want the
page to refresh or anything like that
and then let's create a constant for our
response we'll set it to await
fetch we're going to go to our API to
the tickets
folder oh we didn't create a ticket
folder so our API we should actually
create a folder for that cuz eventually
we're probably going to have more than
just tickets in our applications you're
going to have users or whatever it might
be so let's create a tickets folder
let's move this route ins inside of that
folder so go ahead and move it now we
got a route inside of tickets so we'll
do a weight fetch tickets this will be
our URL that we're accessing for this
post
method so we'll say say our method is
post our body we need to pass the data
to this post method so we'll do string
stringify and then we'll pass in our
form
data we'll do content type of
application
sljs that looks good all looks good
there we'll get to that era in just a
second ignore that for the time
being we'll say if our response. okay is
not true so if there's some sort of an
error let's throw a new errror let's
just say failed to create
ticket now after this we after we create
a ticket we probably want to Route it
back to the dashboard to our ticket set
so here is where we need to use this use
router that we defined
above so let's create a router so let's
say
const router
equals use
router and then here down below so this
is going to throw this air if not if it
doesn't throw that air then we want to
use the router
to refresh the page and then we'll use
router. push to push us back to the
default
page so that all looks good this handle
submit now because we're using an async
function because we're waiting we need
to use the async
above save
that that looks pretty
good I think
so let's go ahead and let's create try
and create our first ticket let's
refresh this page just to make sure and
we'll say I dropped my
PC please fix my
PC I dropped it
today I will
be
waiting your
response
we'll say this is a hardware problem
give it a priority of two not started
yet create that
ticket and it through an air let's see
if we have
anything okay one thing we can do we can
do control shift I this will bring up
our console
here status of 404 not found API
tickets that's probably because of how
we had it structured and I kind of moved
things around there so inside of our API
folder there's tickets and we have our
route the post route inside of
it let's do
a console.log here and see if that hits
we're inside the tickets folder go back
to TI get
form weot a slash here let's add that
slash back
in leave everything the
same ah this import is now different
because we move that so we need two SL
two dot dot slashes to go back up two
directories all this is because I didn't
structure go back in our route so for
our route we're going to add
another do
slash cool so that looks like it worked
it kicked us back to the main page but
you'll also notice
that um it didn't give us the updated
ticket which makes sense because we're
displaying these default tickets we're
not actually displaying our live
data so if we go back here we can see
that we've actually successfully created
a ticket so that's cool I dropped my PC
blah blah blah let's go back here and
actually in our route I'm curious if I
can replace this whole
mess with
at and then app slm models like that
that should take us to the base of the
app let's try and create another ticket
and just see if it
works I dropped the
server this is way worse please fix it
now this is also a huge problem let's
make this a
five and create the ticket you'll see
that worked as well so that at symbol
did work for us that'll probably clean
it up so if we move things around it
won't be an issue next time and you'll
see now we have two tickets awesome so
now we're creating tickets in our
database so we got to create function
down of our database but we're not
showing those tickets we're still
showing the default tickets here so
let's go ahead let's create one
more create a map of our whole
network we'll create something like this
we'll say it's going to take some time
we'll make this a project we'll give it
a priority of two we might already have
something done so we'll add a little
progress and we'll say it started create
the ticket so now we should have three
tickets two different
categories yep and that's in our
database as well so that's all good to
go now what I would like to do next is
let's create a route to get all of our
tickets cuz cuz right now we're showing
default tickets but we don't really want
to show default tickets we want to show
our actual tickets that are stored in
our database so let's create a new async
function for
get now this is inside the tickets
folder in our route folder we can do a
try catch for this as well our catch can
be the same so I'm going to copy that
paste it so we got our catch and then
here to get the tickets we're going to
do const tickets equals a
weit
ticket
find we're just finding all of them you
could do some filtering here you know
only find Open tickets only whatever but
we're not we're not there yet so we're
going to keep this the same and when we
do that we want to return a next
response instead of this we want to
return our
tickets
and we'll give a status of 200 that's it
pretty
simple so now we should have a way to
get our tickets into our project and
let's go to our main page so inside the
app now this can get a little confusing
because we have multiple Pages um but
inside the base level app where we're
displaying our ticket cards let's open
that
up and the first thing I want to do is
create a con
to get create a variable to get our
tickets this is going to be an async
function because we got to wait for
it we don't need to pass anything to
this one right because we're just doing
we're just trying to connect and grab
out the tickets this will be a good look
so let's create a const for our response
equals a weit let's fetch our
tickets this time we're using the server
we're not using client s side so we have
no used server up there so we need the
full
URL I
believe to
API make sure this is capitalized
tickets so this should get our
response do a
comma inside here we just want to ma
mention that we don't want to store this
data so every time this runs we want to
check and see if there's no if there's
new data inside of
this if there
is we want to Res turn that
response like
that and if
not we can console.log out our
err you can make this a little more
descriptive failed to get tickets that
looks great right so now here inside of
the dashboard we need to actually use
that new function so let's destructure
tickets from await get
tickets this dashboard needs to be an
async
function Willow wait get tickets so now
we should have our tickets now I want to
map over and get all the unique
categories we have so I want to kind of
separate out these tickets by category
so buy software buy hardware and buy
projects in our case um we don't have
any software yet I don't think but we
might in the future so let's get all of
our
unique categories let's set that equal
to an array what we're going to do is
we're going to D structure a new set so
what set's going to do is it's going to
take all of our results and it's it's
going to remove the duplicates
essentially so we're going to do
tickets.
map we're going to destructure our
category
singular and then we're going to return
each time that category so all we're
going to do is we're going to map over
all the tickets and every time we have
an individual ticket in our list of
tickets we're going to grab out the cat
ategory and we're going to return it
then we're going to pass that to a set
so what that's going to do it's going to
remove the duplicates so now inside of
here in our case we should have Hardware
problem and project as our two unique
categories we shouldn't have software
because we don't have any tickets yet
that have
software so now inside of this we can
delete out all of our placeholder ticket
cards so in side
here let's do another
div and below this
div we're going to say if we have
tickets so if
tickets is available we want to take our
unique categories and we want to map
over
those for each unique
category
now make sure this is singular so unique
category we're going to get the unique
category and we're going to get a
category
index every time we have that we're
going to create a
function and every time we have
one we're going to create a new
div
opening and
closing and this div we're just going to
give it some space here so mod margin
bottom
four and we also need to give it a key
so we're going to set the key equal to
our
category index here just like
that so this is going to give us
whenever we're mapping over we need to
give it a unique key a unique identifier
so that's why we're passing in that
category index and then inside of this
let's give an
H2 and this is going to be simply our
unique category so it's going to give us
a header of whatever category we're
currently
under then let's pull this out of
here let's put it below that
H2 so now we we have our new ticket grid
here I'll save it just to format a
little bit for you guys and now let's
spit out our tickets so with our tickets
we want to do
filter we're going to grab that One
Singular ticket and we're going to say
if the ticket.
category
equals the unique category we're
currently on not the unique categories
singular so unique category so if the
current ticket matches the category
header that we're displaying here then
we want it to show up
right so if that's the case we want to
do
map and this is going to be our filtered
ticket and our underscore index
here
now what we can do now once we get to
this point we know we have a ticket and
we know it matches our current
category so now we can pass our ticket
card like
that but we also need to pass some more
information remember our ticket cards
are static right now we're not passing
in any actual data so we want to give it
an
ID and the ID is going to be underscore
index and the key is going to be
underscore
index and we're also going to pass it
the ticket information which we'll call
ticket pretty
easy so now we're passing all of our
information into here now remember this
ticket's still going to be static
because in our ticket card we're not
using this yet but that's okay we will
be here
shortly so we can save
that and we don't want to pass ticket
here we want to use this filter ticket I
could tell because it was gray out we
want to get just our filter ticket that
would have been a weird bug
later and you can see now although the
ticket information isn't correct you can
see it's updated to fall under Hardware
problem or project and we have three
tickets which does match the amount we
entered so we're getting closer
so now we're actually passing this data
to our ticket card we need to update
that ticket card to utilize that
information
instead so if we go to our ticket card
now we're being p a ticket to this so we
can destructure you're going to use your
curly braces here and we're going to
destructure that
information and then the first thing we
want to do is priority display so for
priority display we want to now pass in
our priority that we want to use and we
want to use ticket. priority so now
inside of this priority display we're
going to utilize this new one instead of
hardcoding it so what does that look
like if we open that up and you can
control click on this to open it up or
you can open it up over here I'll
control click if you open this up now
inside of our priority
display we can destructure the priority
that we were just passed
in now with that
priority we can dynamically edit these
so they're not always all red we want to
use that priority value so if we want to
do that we can switch these to back
ticks let's switch these to back
ticks and then I'm going to wrap it in
curly
braces so now we can add variables
inside of
here so the first thing I want to do is
let's add some padding to the right of
one
and then we want it only to be read if
it's a priority one ticket so let's
use these curly brackets and we're going
to
say if our priority is greater than
zero if our priority is greater than
zero we want this ticket to be red
otherwise we want it to be some other
color
let's get this just so it's a little
easier for you to understand
here okay so we got a conditional
statement here so if this is true this
first quotation mark is going to happen
so we want it to be red if it's not true
then we want the text color to be
slate 400 so this is just going to be
like a
gray so hang with me here this is is a
little bit different but let's copy all
this and let's replace all of
these so now if our priority is greater
than one we want this one to be colored
if it's greater than two we want this
one to be colored three and
four we want this one to be colored so
now we're using that priority
information that we're passed in and if
you look at these they all have zero
priority which isn't great right that's
not
correct because we didn't save our
ticket card let's save
that and now you can see it's Dynamic so
this part should be updating so we have
a hardware problem one has five stars
and one has two
stars and if we go here we have a
hardware problem one has five
stars and the other has two stars so
that that makes sense or two fires stars
and my
fires so the priority display should be
hooked
up let's go back to our card right here
we can go ahead and update our ticket
header as well so let's use curly
brackets and do ticket.
tile here we can do curly
brackets do
ticket.
description
those should update
now see now we're getting Dynamic data
here as well our statuses aren't correct
or progress bar isn't correct that's
okay we got to go back and create a
delete block you can't delete tickets
right now so we got our title we got our
description for the time this one's
going to be a little unique it's going
to be a time stamp right now but let's
use curly brackets and let's do ticket
dot look at our database it's called
created at
you could use the update as well I guess
created
at so that should show up
now you'll see we got this pretty time
stamp we'll deal with that in a moment
and our progress display we want to pass
in our progress so that progress will be
equal to ticket.
progress and our status is the same way
we want it to status equal
ticket.
status so now these won't show up yet
obviously we have to enter the actual
data on the ticket so let's open up
progress display following the same
format we want to destructure our
progress and now instead of hardcoding
in 75 here so instead of hardcoding this
in we want to use
fatic
and then we can do dollar sign and pass
it whatever our progress variable is we
still need the percent here so that
should be done go back to our ticket
card control click our status so
here we want to use our status instead
so we're destructuring our status and
then here instead of done we want to be
whatever our status is
now if we look at this I remember only
one had progress on it so that looks
like it's correct and you'll see not
started and started are both correct so
the statuses are correct however they're
not the right color so we got a little
more work to do
here you do this a bunch of different
ways let's create a function let's say
this is get
color we're going to pass in the
status that this equal to
status like that again we'll create a
color so we'll say let color
equals we can do BG
slate 700 as our default and then let's
do a switch
case so we'll take our status and Dot to
lowercase this just to be careful in
case we get past an uppercase status or
something like
that now here we can have a case if it's
done we want the color to equal BG D
green-20 which is the color it's using
right now let's go ahead and return that
color then our case if it is
started so we'll say that case is the
color will
equal dg- yellow
-200 then we'll return the
color that a p in there contr s we'll
get all formatted you're noticing I'm
getting sloppy because of this
prettier we say not started as our last
status the color will equal BG red 200
because we need to start that as soon as
possible we'll return the color
and if none of these
execute we can just return the original
color that we set above oops don't put
that
there after your switch case so one of
these returns should hit in our case if
not we just do the gray um background
default or whatever it is there now if
we slide over now we don't want to
hardcode in this 200 right so we want to
utilize our function so what we can do
is change these to back
ticks like so make sure you delete out
the extra one we can highlight all of
this put it inside curly
brackets like that we want to delete out
the background color of green we don't
want that anymore we'll do dollar sign
curly brackets so now we can inject a
variable here we can do get color we can
pack pass in our
status that should be it so it should
look something like this get color and
status with it wrapped around like that
let's see if it worked and now we got
our correct colors we are making crazy
progress here so we got our priority we
got everything on the ticket formatted
except the date
time I'll show you kind of a neat way to
take care of that so back in our ticket
card let's create a cute little function
to format our timestamp so let's let's
say
const format time
stamp
equals we'll pass it a
timestamp do something like
that so for this we need to set some
options of how we want it to look so
totally up to you but let's do year of
numeric let's do month of two digits
so we'll do a two-digit
month let's copy
this we'll do day hour and
minute so after month let's do
day
hour and
minute and then let's also after this
let's say hour 12 equals
true so this is going to give us the
options of how we want our date to look
again obviously you can do whatever you
want let's set a con date equals new
date and let's pass in our timestamp so
now we have a date object that matches
our timestamp that we set and now let's
format
it formatted
date equals date
do2 local string like
this en. us or whatever you want to
format it to let's do comma then pass in
our
options now the most important thing in
any
function if you need data back is
returning the
data I don't know should this not have
two T's that spelled right formatted I
don't think formatted has two
T's so we're returning that format a
date so now in instead of using this
pure timestamp here so we use this
ticket created at instead of that we can
call our formatted Tim stamp and pass in
that Tim
stamp now if we take a look at this this
looks much better so now we have our
tickets working we have all the data
showing up we can create tickets now we
need to be able to update and delete
tickets as well so that's what we're
going to cover next
all right so we still have two functions
of our crud application that are not
functioning yet we need to create our
delete function and our update function
as well let's go ahead and Tackle delete
first I think it's a bit easier let's go
back to our code into our API now this
one's going to be unique inside of the
API folder let's right click on tickets
and create a new
folder and for this one we're going to
use the square brackets and ID again so
what we're doing here is we're going to
create an API that can access and delete
a single ticket or delete or update a
single ticket so we're going to use
these Square params again and if we
right click on that we're going to
create a new file and we're going to
call it route doj again the name is
important there so we have one route. JS
inside our ID folder and we have one
inside our tickets folder now the
Imports are pretty similar so let's do
import ticket
from we can use our at symbol this time
app slash
models
ticket that looks pretty good and then
we'll also
import
next response from next server that
looks
good this one's pretty simple so it
shouldn't take too much
here we're going to export async
function
delete we're going to use request and
we're going to grab off the pams so we
want to grab the parameters that we're
passing in so we know which ticket to
delete we can do this inside of a try
catch like we did with our others if
there's an
error we can just return that response
like we did with the
others we can give a message of error
and we can also pass the
error we can also return a status of 500
or something like that that can be our
err block for this we want to grab off
the ID from our
prams
then we want to
await ticket. find
by by
ID and
delete and we want to pass the
ID then if that's all executes we can do
next response
again we can copy this for our message
we want
tiet
deleted don't need the
erir we can give a status of 200 so this
should be our delete
function now we need to actually hook
this up and make it function so let's go
back to our delete block
here and we're going to create
a delete ticket
function it's going to be an async
function just like we did with our other
ones inside here we can do constant for
our response it'll equal a weight let's
Fetch and then we'll pass our delete API
URL so it's local 3000
API tickets plural in our case slash and
then we want the ID now this is where
you have to make sure your folder
structure over here is okay and correct
we want this route inside of the square
bracket ID so then from
here we can pass in our ID value for
whatever ticket we're working on now
it's also important for our delete Block
in general we're going to now have to
pass it an ID off of that as well so
we'll have to update that on our ticket
get card here in just a moment so we got
our
response oops I wasn't quite done there
put a comma after
this do our method
is
delete and we'll say if our response is
okay want to do
router.
refresh
this is going to be
lowercase and we got to create that
variable just like we did with our other
where we created a router so we'll say
con router equals use router now this is
the one again you want to be careful we
want to import next navigation use
router so you can see my import is next
navigation make sure that's the way on
yours too or else it won't function
correctly now we need to call this
function so we'll say on
click equals delete ticket bam now this
is
functioning but we're not at the moment
passing in an ID so we're going to have
to fix that so let's go back to our
ticket
card and inside the delete block now we
need to pass an ID so we can say the ID
equals our
ticket doore ID so this is saved inore
ID in mongodb
save that let's go back to our delete
block we have an error here um this is
because we're trying to use an
interactive component so we need to use
client side JavaScript so we need to
explicitly say we want to use the client
up
here to take care of our issue that
looks pretty
[Music]
good so now if we go back to our
application and I've actually had this
sitting for just a bit so I'll hard
refresh it just to make sure so that
looks good we have our project and our
two tickets let's delete the I drop the
server
ticket can't resolve the
tickets go back
here that was in the delete block I
believe
oh wait no it was in the route
here oh silly me I needed parentheses
around
this my
bad okay so if we go back here refresh
this make sure we're all up to date we
should be
anyways H that we get another error
router. refresh is not a
function silly me this use router should
be a function that should resolve our
issue there so now this might have
executed because it hit that so yeah we
did delete it and then it aired out
afterwards so we we did delete that
ticket let's delete the project
one and you'll see that works correctly
we refresh we only have one
ticket now if we go to mongod DB you'll
see reflects that in our database as
well we've successfully deleted those
tickets awesome so we should be good to
go there that is functioning
correctly now we have just one more to
functional component to add to our crud
here and that's the update functionality
so we're going to do this kind of
uniquely I only want one ticket page so
we're going
to decide whether it's whether we need
to update a ticket or create a new
ticket based on the parameter we're
passing in if we go to our ticket card
first we want to add a link to this so
when we click on a ticket we want it to
take us to the update ticket page right
so on our ticket card we need to add a
link here so what we can do is we can
wrap this whole section in a link
tag so let's start the link right above
the
H4 and then we'll do it right below the
status display here so there should be
one div after the link tab if we save
this it's going to puke because it needs
the hre
here so we'll go ahead and set that up
so we'll say hre equals curly brackets
back ticks because we're going to use
some variables here we want it to go to
the ticket page now remember we have to
pass a parameter to go to the ticket
page because it's in that ID so in this
case we want it to give the ID of the
ticket and we want the style variable
here as
well so what we're going to do is we're
going to pass in to make sure it
displays contents so essentially this is
going to allow our CSS to pretty much
ignore this link tag so it's not going
to change the structure here we're just
adding in the link is all we're
doing and of course we need to import
this I'll use intellisense there you can
see it added my link from next link that
should be
good that should be working so now if we
go back to our application we only have
one card we're running out here you'll
see I now have like the pointy Arrow
over the whole thing if I click on it I
do go to the ticket app so that is a
positive we go to the ticket app we have
the correct ticket ID but obviously it
doesn't look like we're updating it it
still has create your ticket create your
ticket and we don't have any update
functionality
either so when we click on this remember
we're going to the ticket page so inside
of our close the components inside of
our ticket page folder we have an ID
folder and then the page here and right
now we're just rendering that ticket
form we're still going to pull off the
pams we definitely need those now and
then inside of this we're going to
create a constant called edit mode so
this is going to tell us if we're
editing a ticket or if it's a new ticket
that we're cry trying to create so
remember if it's a new ticket the ID
will
equal new
otherwise it's going to be something
else so we can set up some conditionals
here so all this is doing it's going to
check our parameters to see if it equals
new if it does update mode is false and
we know or edit mode I'm sorry so we
know that it's a new ticket otherwise
edit mode is true and if we look at this
we can tell that see if we had ran this
edit mode would be true because this
does not equal new but if we use the new
ticket button you'll see on the same
page we have a pram of new so that's
going to be what
drives whether this is updating a ticket
or creating a new
ticket so let's go ahead and say if we
have edit
mode so if we're editing a ticket we
need to get our update ticket
data we'll set a variable for that as
well so we'll say
let data equal blank object like this so
then if it's edit mode Let's go ahead
and create a function to get our ticket
by ID now technically we could probably
pass all the tech ticket data down from
the function above but I wanted to do
this so we can show how to get a single
ticket we have a function where we're
getting all the tickets let's create one
to get a single ticket so we're going to
await that ticket data remember this
function doesn't exist
yet and then down here we can just
console.log out that updated ticket data
for right now we obviously don't have
this
function and this needs to be async
now then up here we can do
const get ticket by ID this equals an
async
function we'll pass in an
ID we can do our try catch if there's an
error let's just console.log out that
error for right
now we'll await our fetch let's use back
ticks again cuz we're going to pass in
that variable
HTTP localhost colon 3000
slash API slash tickets slash dollar
sign ID this doesn't exist yet but a
comma curly brackets and we want
to not store this data so we want to
grab the data every
time to no store
that looks
good let's do it this way actually
instead of the try catch block let's say
if the response isn't
okay and we want to throw a
new
air failed to get
ticket so we can actually kill this try
catch that and we'll just throw a new
err if we don't get
it otherwise we want to return our
response.
Json like that okay so now we have this
all but this API does not exist yet so
we need to create that don't worry it's
very easy so we're inside the route. JS
inside the square bracket ID folder
remember that's very important we're
needing to use the ID again with this
one
so on top here let's create export
Port
async function
get we're going to get some
requests we're going to get pams this
time as
well off of those pams we can grab our
ID very similar to what we did for the
delete we'll grab our
pams we can get our found ticket data
and set it equal to await
ticket.
find
one where the underscore
ID is equal to the ID per Ram we grabbed
above so it's going to find our specific
ticket and then we want to return
next response.
Json let's return the found
ticket and let's also return a status of
I guess to stay consistent we should put
this in a try catch as well let's copy
all this
Jazz put it inside of our try and then
our air is going to be the same so let's
copy that paste
that that looks pretty
good okay so now we should be able to
get our ticket data and it should
console.log it out now this is going to
be on the server side so it should go in
our terminal inside Visual Studio code I
think click on that goes to this page
that all looks
good and you'll see it does have our
found ticket data now you'll also notice
it's inside a found ticket variable
here so if we go back to our ticket page
so let's go
back sorry guys I need to
start closing out of these more
often so on here let's close out of our
components close out of our API for the
moment our ticket page we're going to
the one in theore ID so we're opening
that up you can see we're getting our
ticket by ID that worked we console
logged out this data here now was in a
found
ticket variable there so we can actually
do if we want to just do something like
this State ticket data
equals dob ticket that should work
little
dirty so now this should have our ticket
data that we can pass down to the ticket
form
otherwise if it's not
edit mode so if we're not editing a
ticket we just want our update ticket
data to
have an underscore ID of
new and then either way we're going to
pass down the ticket
data to our
form so now no matter what we're passing
it into our form so now on our form so
open back up the components open up your
ticket
form we can do some cool conditional
rendering and we can either update or
create a new ticket based on the ticket
information that we're passed
here so here we have our starting ticket
data and below this we can update it if
we're in edit mode so we need to create
that variable as well
well so we can do something very similar
to our
other program we can do edit mode equals
ticket doore
ID
equals
new this is
false otherwise it's
true we got to destructure our here as
well so when it's passed in so our edit
mode now if the ticket ID equals new and
we know we're not editing a
ticket otherwise it's going to be true
because we are editing our
ticket so now we have our starting
ticket data this is for a new ticket so
what we need to do is we need to check
if we're in editing mode if we are in
edit mode then we need to update all
these values so if we're in editing mode
mode our starting ticket
data. tile is going to equal ticket.
tile we're going to have a few of these
so we'll have description priority
progress status and
category so we'll do
description
priority
progress
status
category so now those should all work
and now we're making this change before
we create the state so the state should
be updated if we're in edit mode here
so we got I dropped my PC and then if we
go here you'll see that we are looking
like we're editing this ticket now we
don't have any functionality to actually
create to actually edit the ticket yet
we don't have an update function so
we're going to do that next but let's do
some conditional rendering here to fix
this so it looks like we're updating a
ticket so if we scroll
down we have this H3 that says create
your ticket let's make this a bit more
Dynamic depending on if we're editing or
creating a
ticket so
let's put this inside curly
brackets this is eventually going to be
a string to create your ticket we'll put
that inside of quotes now we need to do
some conditional rendering so the first
thing we need to check is what is edit
mode set at so if edit mode is true so
if edit mode is true remember we want to
update your ticket and then we'll do
a colon there and if it's false we want
create your ticket to show
up now let's copy this and we're going
to do the same thing for our submit
button more or less so submit the value
currently is create your ticket we want
to make that Dynamic and we'll say
that's update ticket if it's true or
create ticket if it's false so now if we
go back to our project you can see it's
update your ticket update ticket so this
looks a little better and now we're
showcasing that we're not just creating
a ticket here we're updating a ticket if
we go to a new ticket so remember
clicking on this goes to the new
ticket you can see we don't have an iore
ID on your
ticket go back here to our
[Music]
page let's do this let's
console.log out our edit
mode and let's also do our update ticket
data see where we're messing this up
update mode is false our underscore ID
equals
new that did work now maybe it just
didn't hadn't updated
yet if I click on here we got our update
ticket go back here yeah that's working
now must have just not updated correctly
so we can delete this out it is
functioning that looks good so now let's
go back to our ticket form we need to
change some things right so
obviously in our handle submit here it
gets a little more complicated now right
we don't want to just post our new
ticket every time because right now even
though we say update it's not going to
update the ticket it's going to create a
new ticket still we need to fix
that so essentially this first line is
going to stay the same regardless and we
want to
refresh and push our back to the
dashboard regardless so everything else
will go inside an if
statement
so if we're in edit
mode we want to do something else right
we want to update our ticket
else we want to do all of this
Jazz that's how it should look let's
tuck everything inside this lse
statement for our creating of a new
ticket and then we just need to
edit our new ticket actually we can
probably copy some of this it's probably
similar let's copy that so now now we'll
just edit this first one to be our
update so for this we're going to the
tickets folder but we're going one more
directory because we have to pass in our
ID so we do dollar sign like this ticket
doore ID needs to be passed in now these
need to be changed to back
ticks so we can use that variable
inside and then highlight all this and
put inside curly no we don't need to do
that sorry n this should be good so that
looks good and then instead of the post
we need to put so we're going to update
our
data content typees the same our body
can be the same with the form data being
passed in so that all looks pretty good
I think actually
simple fail
to update ticket how about
that okay now back to our API inside the
ID folder remember we can't be on this
base one we need the one that's inside
of the square bracket ID let's create
our update
function I'm going to copy our
delete paste it
below I'm going change this to put we
need our request we need our prams we
need our ID still so that is good but
now we need to get our body data so
let's
do const body
equals await request.
Json and con ticket data so we're going
to pull it off of the body equals body
do format data like
that that all looks good now let's go
ahead and get our updated ticket or
update our ticket so let's do
update ticket data
equals await
ticket do find by ID and
update we're going to pass in the ID
which we grabbed off our pams
remember we're going to destructure our
ticket data pass that
in that looks pretty
good for our success we just want ticket
updated
then we'll send out our air so that all
looks
great okay little scared to test it out
but we're good so I'm going to go back
to the
dashboard do that did a hard refresh
let's click our new button up here so
let's say creating a new
ticket let's create a report database
this is a
longterm
project using a lot of
resources good luck say this is a
project I just want to make sure the new
ticket is still functioning let's make
it a priority of
three and maybe over 50% we'll say it's
started let's create our
ticket you'll see that all looks good
that's all still functioning but now I
see this ticket is incorrect it needs to
be more important let's click on it now
I can make it a priority
five and let's add some more exclamation
points they were wrong it's actually not
started and this progress should be zero
update our
Ticket No it actually didn't update so
let's check that out
so our new ticket functionality still
works but our update did not
work check out inside of
our go back to our
route let's try this too let's
say before this return if all this is
successful let's
console.log
out say
ran we say our put ran
five so our put function is
running so this price sign simple
but let's also check out our ticket data
and make sure that's updating as well
maybe we're not passing at the right
data
so on this one click here this one
should have no period on the title and
more exclamation points go back to our
log and you'll see our ticket data is
undefined so that's our issue when we're
pulling it off
the uh oh and you'll see I did format
data instead of form
data so now if we run this this should
show up as something instead of UN def
find and that will help us Trace back
our air this might work this time let's
do three exclamation points priority
five progress zero not
started that looks better so now we're
updating our ticket three exclamation
points five fires super hot project and
you'll see that we're good to go there
we can
create another ticket just to make sure
our stuff still works so
say we
spilled pop on my
laptop won't work now no idea
why you ever work tech support this is
kind of how these tickets go so that's a
hardware problem we'll say it's
five not started
boom create ticket goes in the correct
category looks
good that's a pretty good setup right
here we got our create read update and
delete all functioning this is a great
place to get to on this project now you
know the understand and understand how
to use the app router and nextjs 13.4
this is not a production ready
application right now we're sharing
tickets with anybody who goes to it and
it's unprotected we need to add
authentic ation and a bunch of other
stuff as well if you'd like to see me
continue and update this project let me
know in the comments if you want instant
access and questions and being able to
suggest new projects and see updates to
this code that you guys might fix in the
future visit the website and join it's
free you get early access to videos and
this is the only way to request certain
projects for me to do and showcase to
you if you don't mind and you've enjoyed
this video so far please hit that
subscribe button my daughters really
want that silly little plaque for
subscribers so if we could get to
100,000 subscribers that would be
awesome I'm going to continue making
videos for you guys regardless and until
next time keep coding